[Music]
today is the last day of school
before winter break,
how are you greetings from cristian cásseres with his
new newsletter from wisner español the
clark county school district
wants to send a message to parents
so they can talk to their parents  children about the
things they post on social networks
the district reported that there are a series
of violent threats on these
platforms that recently
became a national trend
due to this the school district of
course in being and closing all its
establishments on the day of  today the
authorities ask both
adults and students to
report any suspicious activity i
tell them that a security guard
is recovering in the hospital
after a man opened fire inside
santafé station northeast of the valley
police say this man  started
shooting after a ruckus the
security guard was shot multiple times by
detectives without  However, they believe that
the suspect will survive, he was arrested
and the breakers are preparing to
face the credible browns on
Saturday at half past one in the afternoon for a
visit, but there are problems for the team
facing the bad guys so
far they report that there are 19  players on
the kobe roster while the videos
have none this could change
the picture incredible since they did not
have several of their regular players and
closing and closing taking a look
at the weather forecast we will have
sunny days with temperatures in the 50s like
highs during the day and will drop
to 30 degrees during the night for Monday
we will see the highs reaching 56
degrees while on Tuesday and
Wednesday we will be able to see some rain
here in the valley I am cristian cásseres
with his fierce x-none informative
Spanish good day